nice some movie about people in Seattle
Washington that gets superpowers they're
onto me Chronicle so Chronicles the
newest addition to this whole
found-footage genre and in Chronicle
three high school students go out into
the woods during a party and they find
this crater with a big glowing magical
meteor rock alien thing and now they
have powers which when I saw the trailer
I was like alright this could be cool
but it could be stupid that's what I'm
saying not Chronicle Chronicle does some
really cool the story focuses on
the most interesting of the three kids
he's just one kid he's abused by his
stepdad he's not popular in high school
he gets picked on in high school he gets
slapped around when his stepdads
slapping him around - you're like that's
rough to watch because it's like
found-footage so it just looks more real
but now he and his two friends have
powers now they can do some really good
stuff right help humanity and all that
good well I suppose I could but
when you saw the trailer where this kid
was like crushing the car with his mind
you know it's not really gonna go that
way not entirely anyway funny thing is
when you're watching this movie you see
him get picked on you're like Oh in this
kid gets powers you are let's go oh I
can't wait now saying whether or not it
goes down how you want it to go down I'm
just saying that's what's going on in
your mind there are some scenes where
they do some really sweet stuff though I
mean by the simple concept that you can
move things with your mind you can do a
lot more than just move things with your
mind I mean they learn how to fly and
that would work because you could just
levitate yourself now you can fly you
know stuff like that and that's really
the only gripes I have about this movie
or the fact that when they're flying
around it doesn't look particularly real
I mean the movie looks like it cost
about 5 and a half bucks to make so I'm
not going to about it too much I'm
just saying when they're flying you're
like ah it looks kind of fake yet it's
really cool and liberating because I've
dreamt about this kind of you
haven't dreamt about flying I have a
hundred times now I kind of get to see
it with you know okay special effects
still even though the special effects
weren't so polished in these scenes it
still felt more real than most movies
because it's found footage these are the
strengths that the found-footage genre
bring if they do it right it'll make it
feel like it's really real like you're
living through these people it's cool
when done right I mean it's cool seeing
them develop their powers over time is
cool seeing the journey of this one kid
is just kind of socially outcast if for
nothing else Chronicle isn't one of the
more interesting superhero origin
stories I've seen it's one of the more
interesting supervillain origin stories
I've seen and the end of this movie man
a genius imagine the end of Superman 2
but it's less cheesy and General Zod and
Superman have telekinetic powers but
they don't have heat vision or frost
breath and Superman doesn't have a
cellophane s that he throws off his
chest but other than that it's kind of
what it's like I enjoyed the living
out of Chronicle more than I thought I
would not saying something in the end I
will say I will buy Chronicle on blu-ray
if I can think of a really innovative
superpower origin story it would be
Chronicle actually telekinesis doesn't
work like that and wolves don't attack
people so your favorite superhero or
super villain origin story what is it
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more